the the Hillsdale uh distinguished
Fellowship is a particular honor for me
uh because my maternal grandfather was
born in Hillsdale Michigan and was a if
I think I have remember this correctly
was a graduate of Hillsdale College the
class of
1942 um and so uh it it it it's quite an
incredible thing to have gone you know
last year to to teach a a one credit
course to the college and to to see
Hillsdale and to imagine what it was
like in the 1930s and the depression
when he was growing up and in the 1940s
and after the war when he came back um
and so it's a kind of a nice family
angle but those happy and maybe house
and memories aside we're here to talk
about something uh very serious
something um very dark uh and something
that is threatening families and kids
all over the United States um you've
seen it with uh activist teachers
pushing radical gender theory in the
classroom uh you've seen it with
so-called trans influencers polluting
Tik Tok and other social media platforms
um and you've also seen it unfortunately
and most grotesquely uh in major
Children's Hospitals across the country
uh which are cutting up kids in the name
of so-called gender affirming care and
so what I've been working on the last
year among a few other projects uh is to
try to figure out where this ideology
comes from how it attained power and
most importantly how it can be stopped
uh The Story Goes much deeper than you
might imagine and i' like to take my 20
or 30 minutes tonight uh to tell you the
basic story of trans ideology and how it
migrated into the classroom how it
migrated into the operating room um and
really how it came to conquer a vast
portion of the American
mind the first step of this is to
understand what you might think of as
transgenderism 101 um is to understand
the ideology and it's to understand it
ideologically first and foremost because
it is not a a a sexual orientation um it
is not even uh per se a romantic desire
what it is is a political belief system
that merges ideology with technology
with power and the intersection of those
three forces is really where uh it's
been most successful if we go back to
late 1980s uh you see a group of writers
and and queer theorists and gender
theorists including Judith Butler Gail
Rubin Sandy Stone and Susan Striker who
established the disciplines of queer
Theory and transgender studies the basic
argument is something I think by now
many people are familiar with that
gender is a social construct that's used
to oppress racial and sexual minorities
and the categories of man and woman
represent a false binary that must be
shattered in order to break the broader
system of
heteronormativity a very fancy multi-lab
latinate word uh for for something that
maybe a in the Black Panther era they
would have said very clearly the white
male heterosexual power structure that's
really what they mean by that
um and these gender theorists and then
the transgender theorists after them
made the case that all of these systems
are arbitrary they're contingent um
they're infinitely malleable they're
unrelated to human nature which they
take as a
myth and so the most dramatic way for
them to
deconstruct gender sex man woman is
through transgender ideology and then of
course through transgender
practice and the the basic Gambit here
is that if a man can become a woman and
if a woman can become a man the entire
structure of creation can be
subverted I'd like to quote uh briefly
one of the most influential figures in
this movement a a man called Susan
Striker a male-to-female transgender
Professor one of the founding theorists
um who describes uh his work as quote a
secular sermon that unabashedly
Advocates embracing a disruptive and ref
figurative gender queer or transgender
power as a spiritual resource for social
and environmental
transformation uh uh uh Striker has
taken on some of the verbiage of Judith
Butler you know uh very much kind of uh
dense and and and and jargon laid in
text but in another essay uh that I
think is even more important uh Striker
appeals to none other than Dr Victor
Frankenstein as inspiration this is not
something that you would see today today
it's gender affirming care it's taking
care of kids it's uh someone was born in
the wrong body almost nursery rhyme
language to make the the transgender
ideology in practice seem social
scientific to seem medical to seem uh uh
anod to seem
unthreatening but in the 80s and 90s uh
the true nature of transgender ideology
was revealed in Stark
terms Striker argues that the transexual
body is a quote technological
construction that uh in his framing
represents a war against Western Society
Striker writes quote I am a transsexual
and therefore I am a
monster and this monster is destined
throughout this essay to uh perform a
function of what what he calls rage and
revenge against a series of targets that
we see over and over in this ideology
the naturalized heterosexual order
traditional family values and the
hegemonic oppression of nature
itself these are all of the targets of
transgender ideology and as you see over
time the goal of transgender ideology
starts to merge with other elements of
left-wing thinking it takes on a racial
component trying to bring in the
hierarchy or or rather the hierarchy of
Oppression of race and it also starts to
bring in a specific ideological
objective
um there was a book a collection of
essays titled very uh uh very bluntly
and very straightforwardly transgender
Marxism uh in which activists uh believe
that in order to truly abolish
heteronormativity you had to also
abolish capitalism uh so you know you
think about it quite ambitious we're not
only going to abolish the basic nature
of reality man and woman dimorphic sex
but we're also going to abolish the
entire economic and political system uh
as as a kind of bonus or extra one of
the writers is in this text writes
something very interesting that I'd like
to again quote uh the activist Rosa Lee
argues quote in a different era Marxist
spoke of the construction of a new
socialist man as a crucial task in the
broader process of socialist
construction today in a time of both
Rising Fascism and an emergent socialist
movement our challenge is trans
sexualizing our Marxism we should think
the project of transition to Communism
in our time communization as including
the transition to new communist selves
new ways of being and relating to one
another and I think that together this
represents really the culmination that
most sharp focal point of transgender
ideology it is to erase the distinctions
of human nature it is to uh erase the
categories of man and woman and it is to
Marshall technology towards a utopian
and idealistic political goal Marxism in
some cases um and you know maybe some
Garden variety socialism in others so
academics have been uh you know
bloviating and and uh and uh and and and
writing very uh dense jargon Rich text
that very few people read for many
decades so the question is well Chris
are you cherry-picking are you taking
examples out of context is this really a
a big deal or is this just a couple you
know
couple people uh that are uh speculating
within
Academia the answer I I wish that were
true but the answer unfortunately is
that it's not true and in fact uh what
I've seen in my reporting and what is
obvious and you've seen in your in your
daily life and your reading and your
observation is that this ideology has
taken on maybe a more sophisticated
marketing pitch but it has migrated to
all of our
institutions so that you may have gotten
an email for example that says you know
project manager you you know you know
Rosa Lee or you know Rosa Smith they
them pronouns you know or Zer pronouns
I'm actually currently under a federal
civil rights investigation for refusing
to use Zer pronouns uh so if you think
that this is not something that is being
taken seriously by people in power uh
you are unfort well you are
unfortunately or maybe I wish you were
wrong but unfortunately you're not
wrong but I can handle myself not really
uh concerned about theid admin ation too
much I can I can hold my own but what I
am concerned about is the creation of a
school to gender Clinic pipeline
targeting kids you know Hillsdale
College can defend itself new College of
Florida can defend itself I can defend
myself but in many cases they're going
after kids who cannot kids that are
vulnerable kids that may not have two
parents in the household kids that may
have other uh issues that they're
struggling with they are the explicit
targets of a campaign
uh to recruit them into an
ideology and I've showed that uh over a
long period of time and a long series of
reports and I'd like to just tell you in
one city how this
works you may have heard of this city
it's Chicago Illinois uh it's a big one
and it's a instructive example of how
the ideology spreads because there are a
few a few key influential
people one of them is a man named
Jennifer pritsker um pritsker born James
pritzker in 1950 served a career in the
US Military and inherited a sizable part
of the Hyatt Hotel
Fortune significant amount of cash in
2013 priter announced a male to female
gender transition he was heralded as by
newspapers as the first trans
billionaire uh kind of a a distinction
of some kind
um but whatever a middle-aged man wants
to to do you know okay uh it's his own
private time and dime you know uh you
know perhaps some some latitude should
be afforded but pritsker for pritsker
this wasn't merely a personal decision
This was um an ideological commitment he
began donating Untold millions of
dollars to universities schools
hospitals and activist organizations to
promote queer Theory and transgender
medical
experiments meanwhile another gentleman
named JB pritsker uh uh his cousin the
governor of Illinois signed legislation
pushing gender theory in the state
curriculum and directing State medicated
funds State Medicaid funds towards
transgender surgeries so you have a kind
of inside outside game in politics and
philanthropy funding all of these
institutions creating a core of
activists and then deploying them in
public schools through these
Partnerships as well as in other
institutions the materials that are
produced uh by some of these uh
organizations including lury Children's
Hospital the largest hospital in Chicago
are quite shocking I did a story
uncovering these documents um that were
provided to me by a
source and what they've done is quite
interesting they've recruited radical
gender activists onto the hospital staff
people with no medical training no
medical job no medical function
pure activism laundered through the
legitimacy of the largest Children's
Hospital in the city so they've taken it
out of the ideology of Susan Striker
bellowing I am a monster uh and
appealing to Dr Frankenstein and now
they're saying we're going to work
through the hospitals and through the
schools and legitimize this ideology um
using those means of
transmission so what kind of materials
are they pushing in Chicago's elementary
and middle and high school
schools cover your ears if you're if
you're bashful uh but uh they were not
only exposing children to trans ideology
but to Kink uh BDSM breast binders and
artificial penis Packers um their goal
and they say this explicitly in material
is to disrupt entrenched Norms in
Western society and to guide vulnerable
students for example those who might
suffer from anxiety depression um autism
in particular we've seen towards gender
medicine as the
Cure and this also became policy at many
of these public schools that invited lur
Children's Hospital in to do these uh
activist uh training
sessions and in fact the Chicago Public
Schools explicitly adopted a policy that
teachers and counselors and and
administrators in their Public Schools
um were
required uh to they say maintain the
privacy of students but I would actually
say more accurately uh they were
empowered to facilitate child sexual
Transitions and keep it a secret from
parents getting over a cold excuse
me
and
meanwhile activists are flooding social
media with these kind of messages I'm
sure you've seen them they're they're
quite frightening and they're and
they're quite very much everywhere and
I'd like to read a quote from a a
Chicago area D transitioner someone who
embarked on a transition and then headed
back
and she says quite poignantly when I was
15 I was introduced to gender ideology
on social media and began to call myself
non-binary over the next few years I
would continue to go deeper and deeper
down the trans identity rabbit hole and
by the time I was 18 I saw myself as a
trans
man and of course this person uh went to
the the city of Chicago uh to connect
with not only activists but medical
providers who would provide her with
anything that she wanted as far as
hormones and other
therapies where does this lead you know
trans activists often say that puberty
blockers for example are youve probably
heard this um are um have no long-term
side effects and are completely
reversible you heard this um I
mean in a way the LIE is so Brazen it's
almost uh you shocking but according to
the medical literature it's not
reversible at all in practice you can
have lifelong Health complications but
moreover 95% of kids who begin puberty
blockers move on to cross- sex
hormones only 5% desist or back away and
50% of females who begin cross- seex
hormones move on to trans affirming
surgeries I think it's quite fair to say
is that once they're in they're in for
life